Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince had a
mission to make his country look more
modern before he was accused of ordering
the murder of a Washington Post
contributor over the past four years
Holly Williams has reported inside Saudi
Arabia witnessing changes that many
thought would never come this morning
Holly says the killing inside the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul is a reminder that
any reforms may only go so far Saudi
Arabia isn't a place that likes to share
its secrets this conservative Islamic
Kingdom is veiled its government opaque
a difficult place to investigate the
killing of Jamal hisagi a veteran Saudi
journalist who dared to criticize this
country's all-powerful rulers this is a
bizarre and disturbing story
Saudi Arabia denies that it murdered or
abducted her Shoji Saudi Arabia finally
admitted that Jamal hisagi had died
inside the Saudi consulate earlier a
spokesman for Saudis top prosecutor
claimed for the first time that her
Shoji was killed by a lethal injection
but one thing that's never changed is
Saudi Arabia's vehement denials that
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman was
involved though that hasn't put a stop
to widespread suspicions that he's
culpable to explain its version of
events that has shocked his killers were
Saudi officials gone rogue
the kingdom brought out its suave
american-educated
foreign minister because what Highness
the crown prince has nothing to do with
this issue the Saudi government
desperately wants to go back to business
as usual at this forum in Riyadh last
week they were touting Saudi innovation
she's a female fighter with kind of
Saudi values
the young prince's shadow is everywhere
we'd like to ask ordinary Saudis what
they think about the killing of Jamal
[ __ ] and the allegations that the Crown
Prince was somehow involved but many
people here are simply too fearful to
speak openly and that problem has got
worse since the Crown Prince came to
power the prince portrays himself as a
reformer over the last year we've
witnessed women finally granted the
right to drive more mingling between the
sexes and even rock bands allowed to
perform openly but that hasn't
translated into political freedom and
the proof of that may be what happened
to Jamal hisagi for CBS this morning
Holly Williams Riyadh Saudi Arabia and
as usual some incredible reporting there
from Holly Williams Thank You Holly well
ahead Toni to copal shows us how
brick-and-mortar retailers are getting
creative to keep people coming through
their doors
believe it or not most shopping still
happens in actual stores and to keep it
that way this holiday season big
retailers like Walmart are using new
technology of their own to keep up with
the convenience of online shopping that
story coming up on CBS this morning I
don't know what Tony's buying there and
if you're on the go subscribe to our CBS
this morning podcast available on
Apple's podcast app or wherever you like
to download your podcast via day's top
stories and what's happening in your
world in less than 20 minutes you're
watching CBS this morning